I feel like the first year I was just
like okay stay safe stay home you know
certain elements of my life fell away
new people came into my life but I felt
like my second year I learned like I was
having fun I learned how to I um gave a
new definition to fun like it just looks
different these days I was like going
out I was going to the dinners I was
going to the events I wasn't avoiding
anything I'm having a revelation right
now which is listening to your story I'm
wondering if is that that when you have
a behavior that you know is not serving
you MH I think we lose trust in
ourselves that we're never going to
break that cycle yeah and somewhere
around 2 years was when I started to
trust myself maybe and I'm I'm not I
didn't know it then you saying what
you're saying yeah is making me think
maybe that's a good time to put it out
into the world to your peers to other
people